good morning everybody
you know and just thinking about a
introduction to this presentation i
sort of thought of two words honor and
privilege
it has been an honor and a privilege to
have worked with so many great
uh yale alumni um i didn't have the
honor and privilege of graduating from
yale's program but um you know after
moving to new haven i did have the honor
and privilege of working with many yale
graduates
i've also had the honor and privilege to
work with
many yale students
as a mentor
since 1995 and most recently as a
faculty member here
since 2005
and
so i think it's an honor and privilege
to present some of this data that
represents what our yale graduates have
done in the last 40 years
so we sent out a survey to all of our
graduates
who had email access or whom for we had
a mailing address
non-responders were reminded with a
postal card and
hopefully next week we will be sending
out some more reminders to improve the
response rate which at present is 28
and after um chatting with
marianne ramos last night i realized
that she might know somebody in new york
or new jersey who could help improve our
response rate if the mailing doesn't
work so
well maybe i should say you know new
york or new jersey right
just a little bit about the gender of
our respondents
again the majority being
female and
that would be about 63 percent female
and 37 percent male and i think that
represents
the class composition
at least for the past six years that
i've been at the lpa program so we have
to figure out what the men are doing
for graduates in clinical practice when
asked uh what they have
done after if they practice after
clinical training 97
have practice in some
clinical setting
and the states represented um the
responses
from the survey
i think there were about 36 states that
um we had respondents from and 14 with
no responses so we'll have to check to
see if they have email and if the postal
service is still delivering to those
states
all right
and for our representation from
responses by year i guess we'll have to
send a kudos out to the class of 2003
who
is the winner so far any 2003 graduates
out there no
okay all right so maybe 2002 is the next
one any 2002's all right here we go
i remember the class of 2002 very well
all right
so
when asked about what type of practice
setting the yale graduate
practiced in
and looking at the data
a majority of uh graduates have
practiced in at one point in their
career in the hospital setting at about
76 percent
um the question the questionnaire said
that they one could respond to
one or more than one
practice setting so about 18 have
practice in rural or community health
centers uh 25 percent have at one time
practiced in a physician practice 52 in
a group practice
for the other 15 percent that has been
comprised of
settings like urgent care retail clinics
hospital emergency departments
outpatient hospitals industry and
force corporation
for the
type of practice that our graduates have
have practiced in about 50 percent
of our respondents have at one time or
another practiced in primary care
followed by forty percent in emergency
medicine
ten percent in surgery thirty three
percent in surgical subspecialties
and twenty percent in internal medicine
or internal medicine subspecialties
with six percent in pediatrics david is
your definition of primary care here the
same as the previous speakers
yes
that is correct
and for 34
of other respondents
that has included areas dermatology
urgent care occupational medicine hiv
medicine
gastroenterology hepatology etc
so we're pretty much covering all the
all the options
as far as leadership roles
in clinical practice about 36 percent of
our graduates have
pursued some form of leadership role
after graduation
and the majority of our graduates about
84 percent have participated as
supervisors of pas
so
they've taken on very much a leadership
role in
in their careers 35 percent have been
chief hospital or practice pas
10 percent have been directors of
research
11 percent have been directors of
quality assurance
and 52 percent have had some other form
of leadership role including including
office or practice administrators clinic
supervisors
director of in-office labs
they've been
leaders in education
and also clinic managers
as far as leadership roles in state
societies about 17 almost 17 percent of
our graduates have pursued a role in
their state organization
and as you can see a majority of
those folks have
of those respondents about 16
um
16 of the respondents
participated in leadership roles and 60
66 of those
the most common was a committee member
and 10 percent said that they had
participated in the foundation
of the state society 52 had been
committee chairs
and about 56 were board of directors and
36
um became pa state society president so
that's pretty remarkable number
and we hope to continue that trend
of leadership
as far as leadership in a specialty
society
six percent of our graduates have
pursued
that role in
their postgraduate career
although this is a new trend it's not
surprising that most respondents have
participated as a committee member
that's been about 80 percent of those
respondents and 37 percent were
committee chairs
50 percent were board of directors and
40 44 were specialty society presidents
and almost 13 percent had founded the
specialty society
and then leadership roles within the
aapa
6.6 of our graduates have had some form
of leadership role in the american
academy of physician assistants and the
most
the most common participation rule has
been in the house of delegates at 82
percent
which i think is a pretty astounding
representation for yale
other
categories that sort of ranked higher
counts a committee or council member or
council chair and also board of
directors and we have a few
looks like a few founders one founder of
aapa
well there could have been two that
participated right
for nccpa leadership roles
we've had about 2 percent
that have participated in our
nccpa organization
83 percent
were committee members
67 percent were or have been test item
writers 33 percent board of directors
and 33 percent chair chairpersons of the
board
as far as no one has yet founded the
aapa of the nccpa
for participation in pa education
we've had
69 percent of our graduates have in some
way shape or form participated in pa
education
the most common role
in participating in pa education has
been via a clinical preceptor
and obviously a vital role to the
continuation of the profession so kudos
to all of you who participate in pa
education
and then the next most common
role is a faculty member at 18 or almost
19 percent of our graduates have
participated in at some point in time as
a
faculty member part-time and 10 percent
full-time
six percent of our graduates have gone
on to become program directors and
one-half of a percent
have been deans
in their respective programs
45.7 percent have been clinical
instructors and small group
organizations
for participation in the physician
assistant education association
2.6 percent of our graduates have had a
role as either committee chair or
committee member or board of directors
and i believe our last category is
community involvement
which is
represents about 24 percent of our
graduates have
expressed some
participation in
community leadership roles such as
community activist
health department consultant patient
educator and the list goes on there's
a very large list of community activism
amongst our yale graduates which speaks
to
the fact that we're not only taking care
of patients we're leaders in our state
chapters in our national chapters but
we're also leaders in our communities so
kudos to
those participating in their communities
so just to conclude some of this data
most of our yale graduates have chose to
practice clinically at some point in
their career about 97 percent
yield graduates have had many leadership
roles in many organizations including
the rpa which actually was not reported
and that was an n of two
and being that part of our mission here
at yale to foster leadership
again you know we plan to continue that
that role here as well 69 percent of
yale graduates have been involved in pa
education and again most as i mentioned
most commonly as preceptors
are nearly a quarter of all pa's pa
graduates from yale have participated in
community leadership
there have been some limitations
obviously of this data and that one the
first one being the response rate but
i hope to see that that number improves
in the coming weeks and obviously it
would be others such as recall bias and
and filling out some of the
the survey but
any questions about the data or
yes thought about also including uh as a
component publications and
either as a co-author or a sole author
i think that's important particularly
when you're connecting back you did and
i forgot to put
thank you
you